hello everyone and welcome to the last
game we'll be showing from round three
of this year's Norway chess it is
John and both of them are uh pretty much
in the same situation uh alereza lost
one game and he won one game he lost to
Lucas and defeated mamidarov and nodded
back he lost to Anish giri uh in the tie
breaks here in the Armageddon game he
didn't lose in classical and then he
defeated Aryan tari in round two In
classical so both of them would of
course enjoy a win here let's see what
happened it's uh quite a quite a wild
game it's very hard to say where uh
someone went wrong uh you you guys will
have to help me out with that one so
noted back has the white pieces and he
opens with D4 I'll get as a replies with
the de5 pawn to see for Pawn to C6 the
slot defense Knight to F3 Knight to F6
and now Knight to C3 going for a three
nights variation Pawn to E6 transposing
into the semi-slav uh E3 and Knight beta
D7 and here Queen to C to ambush of the
D3 are the most common moves and there
are over 25
000 games in the database with those
moves so even though Bishop to E2 has
been played quite a lot it can
definitely be considered a sideline as
there are maybe 1200 uh games in the
database but not not really a sideline
but you know not nearly as popular as
those two so uh trying to throw alireza
off guard here a little bit with Bishop
to D6 and now Pawn to B3 another a
fairly rare move here castles is the
most common move we have B3 B6 biology
is a bishop to beat you and now Bishop
to B7 so both players developing their
Bishop pair very nicely both players
Castle the safety of the king side and
now Queen to C2 and now we've again
transposed into the known lines of the
slab of The semi-slab Rook 8 to D1 and
now Queen to E7 developing the queen
connecting Rooks with Rook after E1 and
Rook 8 to d8 both players claim the DND
file for the Rooks and now comes spawn
H3 here a pretty standard movies Bishop
to F1 here we have Pawn to H3 and now
Pawn to H6
uh taking away the G5 Square uh from the
Knight Bishop to F1 and now there are uh
well there are games that reach this
position C5 is a normal Bishop to B4 is
a no move even E5 is a known move but
the move alireza plays is a new one so
after Bishop to A3 it is now as of move
14 that we have a completely new game uh
another back replies by capturing in the
central ones and now e captures on D5
you have to play e captures even though
you'd like to capture towards the center
then you give up the B5 Square uh to
give you an example if if Capra's just
Bishop captures an A3 Queen captures an
A3
sorry about that I had to had to throw
something uh to the to the lower floor
uh we have uh Queen captures on A3 and
now Knight to B5 this would happen if uh
yeah you capture towards the center and
now the A7 Pawn is hanging and the Queen
and there's no good way to handle this
if you try to defend it Queen A5 Knights
to D6 and you are in big trouble so
after C Captain D5 we have e characters
on D5 and now Bishop captures on A3 we
have Queen captures on A3 and now Rook
to B1 uh hoping to get that b for moving
which would kind of trap The Black Queen
on A3 uh so of course all it is it stops
this Pawn to A5 and now Bishop to D3 we
have Queen back to E7 uh and queen to B2
preparing to uh bring the Rook over to
the C file uh we have Knights the E4 and
now Rook beat the C1 uh Knight the G5
offering a trade of knights and even
hoping to mess up um another big spawn
structure in front of the king so Knight
captures Queen captures and now night
day a for putting pressure on that B6
spawn the Knight can't really move but
it also kind of puts the Knight out of
the game and it makes all the rest of
the job of going after that white king a
little bit easier now of course you
can't um grab the G6 where if you could
play rookies a rook to E6 Rook to G6 it
would be great but okay little by little
and you know okay the light Square
Bishop isn't spectacular at the moment
but at some point alireza will play C5
and this bishop will come alive at some
point so here Rook the E6 adds the
defense to the sixth rank Queen to E2
and now Pawn to C5 and now how do you
deal with this well uh another big went
for a very very bold uh bold move you
could just play Queen to G4 stop the
attack but he played the captures on C5
and now alireza just uh frees up his
light Square Bishop he plays Pawn to D4
and he uh threatens Checkmate and G2
okay it's not really a problem Queen to
G4 offers a queen tray Queen back to E7
and now again not uh a lot of ways to to
capture on D4 if you capture with the
pawn you lose the Rook here if you
capture with the queen then Knight
captures or even better Knights the E5
just uh wins on the spot as the queen is
attacked and also the bishop and D3 so
instead we have Bishop to F5 attacking
The Rook here
uh and Knight to F6 so it is attacks no
dirt bikes Queen on G4 Queen back to E2
and now Rook the E5 just attacking the
bishop on F5 and now the question is uh
how to play this do you move the bishop
or do you try something a bit more
active I I will show you what happens if
you move the bishop if you move the
bishop let's say Bishop to B1 or C2 or
D3 uh D captures an E3 will be played
and now uh it's not easy to reply here
if you play F captures on E3 then Bishop
captures and G2 demolishes all of uh the
white King's defenses for example King
Captain You're Gonna Play Knights the E4
and now the Rook the the queen denied
the other Rook will uh slowly but surely
suffocate that white king if even if you
remove some of the attackers doesn't
really matter you don't even have to
capture right away you could play Rook
to G5 check then capture with the queen
uh let's say King if one Queen captures
and E4 now the other Rook comes into the
attack and it's uh well very very
unlikely that you will survive this if a
black plays correctly so what you could
play after Bishop to B1 and captures on
F3 is spawn to F4 but even this doesn't
really work because Rook to D2 just
forces white to give up the queen and
there's really not all that much if you
move the queen of course the G2 Pawn
hangs uh so you're gonna have to play
captures uh on D2 but not like that Rook
you will have to capture on E5 and after
Rook captures an E2 you will also play
Rook captures on E2 and not Knight stage
five you do have two Rooks for the queen
but it's not uh yeah I mean it's not
like it in fobby's position yesterday
uh black is the one who will be pushing
for a win here however this could be the
best option another back has instead he
played Pawn to C6 uh and now we have
Bishop captures and C6 of course you
don't mind giving up a piece because the
bishop on F5 is also hanging Rook
captures on C6 D captures an E3 now not
uh going for the bishop this is much
much stronger and uh King to F1 by
another Beck and now just The Rook
captures on F5 another very interesting
idea would be just to Triple up on the E
file and now how do you deal with the
threat of just Pawn captures on F2 yeah
you have to play Rook to C8 this is the
only way to do it and okay now white
does get to save the bishop but then
Knight to E4 comes and there's so how do
you defend against the Knight to G3
Knight to F2 uh just no good way to do
it you have to play Rook to D1 then
Knight captures an F2 and again it will
be black who will be pushing for the win
here so uh Rook d8 is very nice here
alireza instead goes Rook captures and
F5 he regains the material Queen
captures and 93 and of course Queen D7
avoiding the trade going after the rook
and now Rook at the C1 a rook back the
C1 also Queen to C3 uh not not a bad
idea but Rook the C1 was played Rook to
E8 now and queen captures on B6 grabbing
that pawn now another week is up upon uh
but it is uh you know this is not a Game
of Pawns uh so Knights the E4 uh now
going for that F2 square and now how do
you deal with this interestingly the
only move for white uh is King to G1 in
order to survive this then comes Knight
captures an F2 uh but you don't have to
worry about any checks you'll just play
Rook capture 78 with check Queen
captures and now Queen to C7 offering to
trade queens and if King to H7 white
will also just play King to H2
uh the queen nicely covers this diagonal
and everything is perfectly fine if
Queen T3 uh okay you are very close to
the white king but doesn't really matter
Rook the C5 and white survives this uh
so let's say Rook to F6 the game
continues uh it's pretty good for both
white and black white probably just go
after the Rook with Rook to C6 Rook to
C5 but in the game uh Rook C the D1 was
played he attacked Ali this is Queen and
this is probably the point of no return
for another but only if alireza plays
Everything uh you know uh at engine
level Precision so feel free to pause
the video and try to find this uh this
uh perfect line that allows alireza to
play for the win while I give you a
couple of seconds
okay
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh wild line and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is night
captures on F2 now you might be
wondering what's the idea behind this
move as our Queen and D7 is hanging so
congratulations if you even consider
this the point is if Rook captures on D7
then comes Knight captures an H3 opening
up a discovered check and also all of
these squares are covered by the Knight
and this is covered by The Rook so the
only move you have will be Queen to F2
and then Rook captures an F2 is
Checkmate so this is what alireza found
when he played Knight captures on F2 you
cannot capture the black queen so
instead we have Rook captures 98 with
check uh Queen capture Sunny 8 and now
comes Queen captures on F2 uh you have
to give up the queen there's no way
around it but alireza doesn't just take
it with Rook captures and F2 first he
wants to position his Queen perfectly so
Queen to B5 checked King to G1 now you
play Rook captures on F2 King captain
address and now Queen to F5 with check
so the queen can infiltrate via the C2
square if the King goes to G1 for
example so he doesn't go to G1 he
instead goes to E3 so now alireza
chooses a different path Queen to G5
check King to F2 and now Queen to F4
with check King to G1 and queen to E3
with check with King to F1 and now Pawn
to F5 while it is an is the assistance
of his Pawns in order to deal the the
final blow however it's not gonna be
easy it is possible to create some sort
of a fortress here perhaps don't like
the B2 we have Queen to C3 attacking the
Knight and Knight the C4 we have font A4
there was no way uh of saving those
pawns you have to give up the two points
for the one Pawn uh Rook to E1 and now
just a captures and b3a captures Queen
captures on B3 Knight to E5 now we have
Pawn to G5 uh just marching forward
Knight to F3 and now King to G7 G4 is
also perfectly fine but alireza wants to
I play it to absolute perfection King to
F2 and now King to F6 we have Pawn to G4
not waiting for alireza to advance the
pawn to G4 and now Queen to B6 with
check with King to G3 and now Queen to
D6 with check if you're wondering about
Ponte F4 well it looks very nice it only
helps white create some sort of a
fortress because once The Rook lands on
D2 there's really nothing black can push
forward I mean H5 okay but whether it's
winning you don't want to risk this so
Queen to D6 check instead with King to
F2 and now F characters on G4 H captors
and queen to F4 uh the G4 Pawn is lost
now point being that if you play Rook
captures on G1 there's H5 and if H
captures G4 wins the Knight on F3 so
instead Rook the H1 was played but now
just King to G7 uh now again if you go
for Queen captures and G4 right away
then Rook captures on H6 and the white
is again uh very very close to a draw
Rook the D6 there's just not all that
much you can do to push here and the
black king is white in the open so
instead King to G7 was played guarding
the H6 Pawn white out of moves you have
to play something Rook to G1 was played
and now Pawn to H5 King to G2 you can't
capture because of the same reason G4 is
coming so King to G2 H capture Sun G4
and now Knights the E1 we have Pawn to
G3 by LEDs are going for uh Queen to F
to check Fall by Queen to H2 Rook to F1
and now Queen to E3 so not a lot for
another back to do here if Knight F3
just Queen to E2 with check and now you
either lose the Rook or you defend the
rook and then Pawn to G4 dislodges the
Knight and then Queen to H2 will be
Checkmate so instead after Queen to E3
King to H3 was played but now comes
Queen to F2 and it was in this position
on move 59 that uh
resigned the game and another
spectacular victory for alireza firoza
who played all of the three games that
he played in the first three runs in
classical so alireza has gets to play a
single Armageddon game he really came
here to play a classical tournament so a
remarkable stuff from alireza taking
downloader because with the black pieces
uh for those of you who missed my
yesterday
um yesterday's video or yesterday's
videos these are the standings after the
first three rounds uh Fabiano seven and
a half points uh uh in uh Seoul first
place alireza with six uh points in
second place then Hikaru Nakamura with
five in third place uh Gucci four and a
half in fifth place we have Anish giri
another because Wesley in seventh place
Magnus Carlsen in eighth place mamidarov
in ninth uh and um last place Aryan tari
for the moment uh these were the uh the
head-to-head scores so gookish defeated
the Shakira in in Armageddon alireza
defeated in classical Fabiano defeated
tari also in classical if you haven't
seen him do check it out this my
previous video uh Wesley lost to Anisha
also in Armageddon and the Magnus
Carlsen has defeated Hikaru Nakamura in
Armageddon Hikaru win for the king's
Gambit also if you haven't seen it uh do
check it out I have it on my channel and
of course uh the thing you enjoy most uh
these are the live ratings after round
three so not a lot happening Magnus
Carlsen does seem to be uh the one
losing the most points here he's
currently on minus 8.6 Fabian the
biggest winner in the top 20 he is on
plus 9.6 and we have some movement
alireza also I want some raiding Hikaru
once I'm currently five rating points
you and Eon 4. good cash also in plus uh
in the northern even though he lost this
game still and plus 0.1 but not a lot of
uh you know shifting power in the in the
top 20. uh Corona did go up three three
Square so he's currently world number
three that's a very significant and now
you can see that both alireza Magnus
alireza Hikaru and uh caruana are ahead
of a world champion dingler on the
classical rating list so that's that is
pretty incredible uh so yeah that's the
game I hope you guys enjoyed it very
nicely uh played by alireza today is the
rest today so if you have any other
games that you would like me to show
from you know some other tournaments do
use hashtag suggestion uh we are
continuing uh with the tournament
tomorrow uh so yeah uh this is the game
hope you enjoyed it uh
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful event until
it finishes uh so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your weekend